when I was out for dinner with Andrew  that was a homeless woman she was  begging for money everybody ignored her  Andrew didn't Andrew gave her money and  I asked him why did you give her money  and he said he will always give a  homeless woman money but never a  homeless man and his reasoning was a man  can do anything to make money whether  it's physical labor laying bricks  whatever it is there's always something  a man can do but as a woman gets older  she becomes more fragile and she  physically can't so who always help  women more than he'll help men and that  is contrary to the entire narrative that  we're hearing about him on social media